je pense pas que ça soit jamais vue de
développer un nouveau cours puis de le
mettre en place aussi rapidement la
formation en effet été organisée à
vitesse grand v et c'est le branle bas
de combat dans les centres de formation
qui se prépare à accueillir les
étudiants
tout sera prêt moins de trois semaines
pour sélectionner des étudiants recruter
des enseignants adapter le contenu des
courses coordonner avec les ch est celle
d une mobilisation express sans
précédent pour de nombreuses équipes
le dernier sprint effectivement c'est de
préparer les 500 sacs qu'on a à faire
pour pouvoir remettre à l'élève
lorsqu'il va arriver ces équipements de
protection individuelle également on
était à l'imprimerie la commission
scolaire imprimer tous les documents
qu'on doit remettre à l'élève mais
certains enseignants se sentent un peu
désemparé comme cette infirmière qui
s'apprête à rencontrer ses nouveaux
élèves
ils nous demandent de construire l'avion
en vol mais on n'a pas d'élu minium
c'est ce que cécile pour tous les pores
de la peau
on est pour les livres encore un délit
du coup normal et non l'écho abrégé
maeva certains candidats ont reçu la
confirmation de leur sélection dans les
derniers jours voir les dernières heures
maryline mère à la maison de quatre
jeunes enfants a appris mercredi qu'elle
avait été choisie
ces cinq jours d'avis et go préparation
mentale forêt changement de vie en cinq
jours elle plonge un peu dans le vide
je sais que le cours commence demain je
sac à l'heure mais j'ai pas plus donc je
vais me présenter à l'école à 7h30 mais
je sais pas du tout comment ça va
commencer puis qu'est-ce qui va en mai
même si tout a déboulé rapidement
elle est heureuse d'avoir répondu à
l'appel du premier ministre
j'ai vraiment hâte de commencer j'ai
hâte d'avoir terminé co pour pouvoir
rentrer dans le ch et celle des pour
pouvoir aller et des jeux devant stress
je content ici fanny bussières mcnicoll
radio canada montréal